This lecture is about the text
categorization.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about the text categorization.
This is a very important technique for
a text, data mining and analytics.
It is relevant to discovery of various
different kinds of knowledge as shown
here.
First is related to topic mining
analysis.
And that's because it has to do with
analyzing text data based on some
predefined topics.
Secondly, it's also related to opinion
mining and sentiment analysis, which
has to do with discovering knowledge
about the observer that the human
sensor.
Because we can categorize the authors,
for example, based on the content of
the articles that they have written.
We can in general categorize the
observer based on the content.
That they produce.
Finally, it's also related to text
based prediction.
Because we can often use text
categorization techniques to predict
some variables in the real world that
are only remotely related to text data.
And so this is a very important technique
for text data mining.
This is the overall plan for covering
the topic.
First we're going to talk about what is text
categorization and why we are
interested in doing that in this
lecture.
And then we're going to talk about how
to do text categorisation followed by
how to evaluate the categorisation
results so.
The problem of texture categorisation
is defined as follows.
We're given a set of predefined
categories.
Possibly forming a hierarchy so.
And often also a set of training
examples or training set of labeled
text objects.
Which means that text objects have
already been labeled with known
categories, and then the task is to
classify any tax object into one or
more of these predefined categories.
So the picture on the slide shows
what happens.
When we do text categorization, we have
a lot of text objects to be processed
by a categorisation system.
And the system will in general assign
categories to these documents as shown
on the right.
And the categorisation results.
And we often assume the availability of
training examples, and these are the
documents that are tagged with known
categories, and these examples are very
important for helping the system to
learn patterns in different categories,
and this would further help the system
then learn how to recognize.
The categories of new tax objects that
it has not seen.
So here are some specific examples of
text categorization and
In fact, there are many examples.
Here are just a few.
So first text objects can vary, so we
can categorize a document.
Or a passage or sentence or collections
of text, as in the case of clustering
the units to be analyzed can vary a
lot, so this creates a lot of
possibilities.
Secondly, categories can also vary, and
we can generally distinguish two kinds
of categories.
One is internal categories.
These are categories that characterize
content of text object.
For example, topic categories.
Or sentiment categories and they
generally have to do with the content
of the tax objects, direct
Characterization of the content.
The other kind is external categories
that can characterize the entity
associated with the text object.
For example, authors or entities
associated with the content that they
produce.
And so we can use their content,
determine which author has written
which part, for example, and that's
called author attribution.
Or we can have any other meaningful
categories associated with text data,
as long as.
There is a.
There are, there's a meaningful
connection between the entity and text
data.
For example, we might collect a lot of
reviews about a restaurant.
Or a lot of reviews about the product.
And then these text data can help
us infer properties of product or
a restaurant.
In that case, we can treat this as a
categorization problem.
We can categorize restaurants or
categorize products based on their
corresponding reviews.
So this is example of external
category.
Here are some specific examples of
applications.
News categorization is very common, has
been stuided.
A lot.
News agencies would like to assign
predefined categories to categorize
news generated every day.
And literature article categorizations
another important task, for example, in
biomedical domain,
Is this mesh annotations , mesh stands
for medical subject heading.
And this is ontology of terms
characterize content of literature
articles in detail.
Another example of application spam,
email detection or filtering right?
So we often have a spam filter to help
us distinguish spam from legitimate
emails, and this is clearly a binary
classification problem.
Sentiment categorization of
product reviews or tweets is yet
another kind of applications where we
can categorize content into positive or
negative or positive and negative or
neutral.
so you can have the same sentiment
categories assigned.
to text content.
Another application is automatically
email routing or sorting, so you might
want to automatically sort your
emails into different folders, and
that's one application of text
categorization, where each folder is a
category.
There is also another important kind of
applications of routing emails to the
right person to handle.
So in helpdesk email messages generally
routed to a particular person to handle
different people attempt to handle
different kinds of requests and in many
cases a person will manually assign the
messages to the right people.
But you can imagine you can build
automatic text categorization system to
help routing a request.
And this is to classify the incoming
request in to one of the categories
where each category actually
corresponds to a person to handle the
request.
And finally, author Attribution.
As I just mentioned, is yet another
application, and it's another example
of using text to actually infer
properties of some other entities.
And there are also many variants of the
problem formulation and so first we
have the simplest case, which is a
binary categorization where there are
only two categories and there are many
examples like that information
retrieval or search engine applications
would want to.
Distinguish it relevant documents from
non relevant documents for a particular
query.
Spam filter is interesting.
Distinguishing spams from non spam.
So also two categories.
Sometimes classification of opinions
can be in two categories, positive and
negative.
A more general case would be K-category
categorization and there are
also many applications like that.
There could be more than two
categories, so topical categorisation
is often such example where you can
have multiple topics.
Email routing would be another example
when you may have multiple folders, or
if you route the email to the right
person to handle it, then there are
multiple people, to clasify
so in all these cases there are more
than two kinds of categories.
And another variation
to have hierarchical categorization,
where categories form hierarchy,
again, topical hierarchy is very
common. Yet another variation is joint categorization. That's when you have multiple categorization tasks that are related. And then you hope to kind of do joint categorization. Try to leverage the dependents of these tasks to improve accuracy for each individual task.
Now among all these, binary
categorization is most fundamental and
partly also because it's simple and
partly it's cause it can actually be
used to perform all the other
categorization tasks.
For example, K category categorisation
task can be actually performed by using
binary categorization.
And basically we can look at each
category separately and then the binary
categorization problem is whether
object is in this category or not.
Meaning in other categories.
And the hierarchical category
categorisation can also be done by
progressively doing flat categorisation
at each level.
So we can first categorize all the
objects in tune.
It's a small number of high level
categories an inside each category.
We can further categorize into sub
categories etc.
So why is text categories important
well, I already showed you several
applications, but in general there are
several reasons.
One is text
Categorization helps us enrich text
representation, and that's to achieve
more understanding of text data that's
always useful for text analysis.
So now with categorisation, text can be
represented in multiple levels, meaning
keyword bag of words representation as
often used for a lot of text
processing tasks.
But we can also add categories and they
provide 2 levels of representation.
Semantic categories assigned can
also be directly or indirectly useful
for application.
So for example, sentiment categories
could be already very useful, or author
Attribution might be directly useful.
And.
Another example is when semantic
categories can facilitate aggregation
of tax content, and this is another
case of.
Applications of text categorisation.
For example, we if we want to know the
overall opinions about the product, we
could first categorize the opinions in
each individual review as positive or
negative, and then that would allow us
to easily aggregate all the sentiments
and it will tell us about 70% of the
views positive and 30% are negative,
etc.
So without doing categorization it will
be much harder to aggregate such
opinions.
So it provides a concise way of coding
text in some sense based on our
vocabulary.
And sometimes you miss seeing some
applications, text or categorization is
called a text coding encoding with some
controller vocabulary.
The second kind of reasons is to use
text categorization to infer properties
of entities.
And text categorisation allows us to
infer the properties of such entities
that are associated with text data.
So this means we can use text
categorization to discover knowledge
about the world in general, as long as
we can associate the entity with text
data, we can always use the text data
to help categorize the corresponding
entities.
So it's useful to think about the
information network that will connect
the other entities with text data.
The obvious entities that can be
directly connected are authors, but you
can also imagine the authors
affiliations or the authors ages and
other things can be actually connected
to text data indirectly.
Once we can make the connection, then
we can make predictions about those
values.
So this is a general way to allow us to
use text mining tool.
Sorry, text categorization to discover
knowledge about the world.
Very useful, especially in big text
data.
Analytics, where we are often interested in
using text data as extra sensor data
collected from humans to infer certain
desicion factors.
Often together with non text data
specifically to text.
For example, we can also think of
examples of inferring properties of
entities.
For example discovery of non native
speakers of a language and this can be
done by categorizing the content of.
Speakers
Another example is to predict the
party affiliation of a politician based on
the political speech at this is again
example of using text data to infer
some knowledge about real world.
In nature this all the problems are all
the same and that's as we defined and
it's a text categorization problem.